Christianity differs in its root ways of
Trinity however the basic concept comes
from the pagan origin how Egypts had
Amon Ray and T as three Gods
Babylonians
Nasha and only no I know I understand so
notice the deceit notice the the
deception the lies the deceit the
trickery he mentions three of the
plethora of gods in order to parallel
that to the Trinity but now go back to
your first example what was the first
example you gave from Egypt Egypt am
and and ra okay and T okay T so but he
is aware and those who studied Pagan
religions are aware these are just three
of many gods and these gods are not in
the sense Eternal uncreated or
Inseparable ah in fact what I would do
is you ask him say I challenge you can
you show me are these three Gods
uncreated by Nature are these three Gods
Inseparable so that they've always
existed inseparably together and cannot
function independently no some of these
Gods precede other gods so that's the
first Lie from the pit of Hell and
that's not just true with the Egyptian
Pantheon that's true with the Babylonian
Pantheon Now give me the other example
of the Babylonian
Pantheon
Nash and Asar ashar okay now ashar is
the
female God she's the goddess how that
how does that parallel the Trinity when
he just gave you two gods and a goddess
who form a Unity but are not Eternal are
not uncreated and are not Inseparable
and these gods and goddesses engage in
sexual intercourse and at times orgies
and that's somehow the parallel to the
Trinity
interesting that's why I can you mention
can you mention the goddess in the
Trinity that we believe in because Asar
is a
goddess so Babylonians are done deal now
Hindu I already know he used Hindu triti
but that stupid argument anyways so if
you want to explain your
audience and Sh okay slowly
are Brahma Vishnu and Shiva now is
Brahma Vishnu and Shiva Eternal
uncreated and Inseparable from one
another no so there are three gods that
come together to form a Unity
right uh in a way yeah but in this they
are not unity in one yeah no what I'm
saying is no you don't have to be Triune
meaning in separably one that's what I'm
saying they come in agreement like you
and I we form a Unity but you're not me
I'm not you we are are separate
independent existences you can exist
without me I can exist without you right
right so in this concept of since you
are familiar Brahma Shiva and Vishnu are
they
Inseparable no are they Eternal
uncreated no have they always existed
inseparably from one
another no and they even fought with
each other thank you say it again they
even fought with each other so they can
exist independent from each other and
oppose each other right yes and this is
somehow analogous to the
Trinity uh no moreover this concept of
theti historically when when is it dated
does it predate
Christianity or is it after
Christianity okay now that is kind of a
little debatable because no I'm not
talking about whether Brahma Vishnu
Shiva was believed on by the Hindus
before the rise of Christianity of
course they're ancient I'm talking about
the belief that they are theti that
phrase where they come together form a
Unity it came much later you know why it
came much later yeah it's it's like 8th
8th to 12th somewhere around that
Century you know
why why because they came up with theti
to parallel the Trinity they were trying
to compete with the Christianity that
already spread and permeated India ah
interesting
that's the one I wanted you to see you
will not find
theti before the time of the Lord Jesus
Christ praise Lord awesome so what this
coward did this tool of the devil this
deceiver did what he did was he took a
later concept that was developed and
coined by Hindus to compete with the
Christianity that already planted itself
and was spreading by the power of the
Holy Spirit in order to get Hindus to
follow a pagan Corruption of the Trinity
and they termed it trti in response to
the Trinity that was already there and
believed on and widespread in
India got it because obviously Hindu
believe in so many gods and goddesses
that I can't even name right now but
this concept perfect thank you thank you
thank you Jes none of them none of them
parallel to the trinity in fact what you
do you say coward I challenge you and
you can say it in your own way you say I
challenge you to show me in any
pre-christian pre Christian religion the
belief of one infinite Eternal uncreated
being who eternally
exists as three distinct but Inseparable
persons however you want to name the
persons but not a a plurality of gods
and goddesses who exist independently
and separately and some Gods older than
the others who have origies and produce
Divine
Offspring oh yeah
exactly you now we'll go ahead to these
other objections you won't find yeah
Greeks I want to handle Greeks and
Romans as well so Greek had
he triple-headed with pepy and selini
man these names are killing me so wait a
Greek god that has three heads and that
parallels the Trinity where the Trinity
is not a three-headed being because the
father son Holy Spirit are
immaterial spaceless and placeless so
the distinction
and their persons has nothing to do with
bodily spatial distinctions see you and
I are distinct bodily and spatially
you're separate from me I'm separate
from you physically and spatially that's
not the Trinity so does he think that
the
three-headed monstrosity in the Greek
pantheon is parallel to the
Trinity uh exactly now by the way when
you said sometimes the terminology is
very hard for me to follow what
three-headed monster
uh hag h e g a d d a ha h e g say it
again h e g a TT a okay and that's
supposed to be what again that is
supposed to be
with who who both prays to Salini s e l
e n okay so no but you said he's
three-headed yes so a three-headed
monster like the mythical three-headed
dog Cerberus Cerberus of Hades and that
parallels the
Trinity apparently he's trying to do
that yeah I'm impressed I'm ready to
leave the Trinity for Greek paganism
what else uh Romans Diana the diva of
three Diana a goddess again with who uh
which is the Diva of triform Diva so
Diana a goddess who's the diva and and
Union with two other gods right yes
and so these two other gods and Diana
parallel the Trinity when they're three
separate gods and these Gods resemble
human beings and that they have bodies
in which they can have orgies and sexual
intercourse and get one another pregnant
and that's parallel to the
Trinity apparently that's his stupid
argument yeah yeah I'm I'm convinced man
I I'm ready to leave the Trinity for
these Pagan trinities perfect the way
you come out is just awesome awesome
so and Persians according to him May AA
Mazda yeah Aur Mazda
and
and IDE
right and challenge him to prove to you
that Aur Mazda and Mithra and what was
the other one because sometimes
pronunciation A n a h i d oh say it
again n a
what h t a okay n a n a h
t
andda i want him to prove these three
gods are Eternal uncreated Inseparable
from one another as opposed to
emanations of a power that some of these
gods are older than others how is that
parallel to the
Trinity excellent excellent so that is
why he started with saying they differ
but the root is of three so that is that
is why he is actually trying the point
he tries
to lessen the differences and
overemphasize the similarities when the
similarities are a joke there are no
similarities understood perfect so he
brushes aside the huge differences to
show they're not parallel in order to
focus on superfici IAL similarities
which are not even similar but are
satanic deceitful rhetoric that he's
using to deceive people into thinking
the Trinity is found in other cultures
it's not and here's the challenge I want
everyone to learn this I want everyone
to learn this ask these people show me
before the spread of Christianity show
me before the time of Christ an ancient
Pagan religions a belief of one listen
to my language one eternal uncreated
being that ex exists as three Eternal
Inseparable Divine persons show me that
then we'll
talk awesome hallelujah
hallelujah so you save me time you save
me time from wasting watching this clown
because this is an argument used by
Joe's Witnesses when I I heard this
argument Joe's Witnesses in the 90s but
go ahead okay got it thank you so very
much it was fast and easy that's good
then he uses Julius Caesar who was
actually in ad44 to 46 if I'm not
mistaken Julius Caesar a human being
born of human parents who is temporal
and finite and fleshly who never claimed
to be the Eternal uncreated God who
became flesh and that's a parallel to
what again uh 1 John 4:14 because he
said that he's the descendant of Aries
and Aristotle The God Who has manifested
and Universal of human life Julius
Caesar
I want him to quote where Julius Caesar
claimed to have been a
pre-existent Divine being who then
became flesh as opposed to being the
sexual Offspring or somehow The
Offspring of a God who himself is not
Eternal the god that SED him who
inseminated his mother or somehow caused
Julius to be a Divine being and that
parallels Jesus being the eternal life
the Eternal Word the true God and
eternal life who became flesh and then
died on the cross to propitiate the
wrath of God for sin and that's parallel
to Julius Caesar saving man how did
Julius Caesar save man from Eternal
wrath and destruction no did Julius
Caesar offer himself on the cross as a
propitiatory sacrifice in order to
appease the Divine wrath so that we
could live forever in the presence of
God no so again what did he do he took
terms that are used by two different
groups that define those terms
differently and somehow deceitfully
satanically impose the meaning of of one
group on this term upon another in other
words I Define salvation one way you
defined it another way but then what I
do is because you use the word salvation
and I use the word salvation somehow I
showed their parallel how's that
parallel just because we use the same
term doesn't mean we have the same idea
or same notion or same definition
I talk about being saved from God's
Wrath by the blood of Jesus and you talk
about Julius CA Caesar saving you from
let's say your Calamity so let's say
from Hunger let's say from starvation
and somehow that's parallel to what
Jesus
did not at all and he was a warrior and
he went in and 100,000 got K that makes
him the savior in the same sense that
Jesus is exactly the opposite basically
so what's the trick what I want you to
hear is the Holy Spirit guides the
conversation so the trick is that they
are using some specific words that we
use exactly that we use as a Christian
uses from these people and trying to say
it's paganism yeah and I'll give you one
more example let's assume here uh let's
assume well it's not assumed they use
this but assume you just heard that you
know what you have in Pagan religions a
belief of virgins giving birth to The
Offspring of the Gods that the gods
cause virgins to conceive and give birth
because you'll hear that they'll use
examples even Bart ER in his book how
Jesus became God it's in his book even
Bart ER admits there is no
parallel to the virginal conception and
birth of our Lord what you find in these
parallels is that a God sees a virgin
and he lust for her and he has sex with
her and he implants her with his Divine
seed to get pregnant with his offspring
so notice the deceit again notice the
deception notice the satanic lie they'll
take the word virgin oh but she's a
virgin and she gave birth to The
Offspring of the God yeah she may have
been a virgin before let's say Zeus Came
Upon her and had sex with her def flowed
her and implanted his seed in her that's
not the same as the virginal conception
of birth of Christ but again because the
word virgin may appear or the notion of
a woman who's a virgin gets impress
pregated by one of these Gods somehow
because she's called a virgin or is a
virgin that's parallel to what
Christians believe
seriously apparently they use that yes
and that's another profound difference
among the pagans their gods were more
akin to human beings glorified human
beings because the gods and the
goddesses were believed to have bodies
and they had genitalia and because they
had bodies and genitalia they would have
orgies and sex with one another and
human
beings you see my point got it how's
that parallel to the Holy Spirit causing
the Blessed Virgin to conceive and give
birth as a virgin physically without
having sex with a man or God coming down
and having sex with
her how's that at all parallel to these
Pagan
perversions basically there's no
parallel because now the God has as a
male Gentile and he is doing that and
here's our belief as Christians and
Christians need to know this Christians
need to know we believe that the one
true God by his very nature is Bod
shapeless formless Timeless and
spaceless why this is just simply
logical if God created time space and
place that means he must have been there
before there was time before there was
space before there was Place well if
he's there before time then he must be
timeless because time did not exist
before he created it and if he's there
before space and place and matter then
by his very nature he must be spaceless
placeless and material
because space place and matter did not
exist before he created them that means
the true God by his very nature is
bodes shapeless faceless placeless so
how then can you compare the virginal
conception and birth of our Lord Jesus
where the Holy Spirit who shapeless
bodes spaceless does not have male
genitalia the father does not have male
genitalia the son became man and as a
man he had a physical body and all the
human characteristics without with the
exception of sin but how do you then
take that view of God and say that
somehow it's parallel to the view of the
pagan gods and goddesses whose gods and
goddesses had physical bodies and
genitalia by which they could have
orgies sexual intercourse commit
fornication and Comm adultery in fact
Zeus was an aerous Pig Zeus was known
for sleeping with married women and not
only that in Greek paganism Zeus is not
Eternal Kronos created Zeus and then
Zeus ended up killing his father Kronos
if my memory serves me
well did you know
that kind of I watched a few videos mov
basically if I'm again I'm going by
memory thank the Lord for she Google
guys confirm real quickly I I I don't
want to speak off the cuff but again I'm
trusting that the Lord will protect me
from error Zeus was created by Kronos
Kronos was his father and then he ended
up killing Kronos and became the king of
the Gods and that's somehow similar
similar to Christianity yeah I'm
convinced man I'm ready to become a
pagan okay while they confir you want I
have the last Point basically yes Justin
merer the the first century Christian
apologist right he's the what Justin
Marty yeah second century second century
sorry second century um his first
apology chapter number I know what he's
referring to that he's talking to the
pagans and saying that what we say is no
more shocking than what you believe
about your gods and goddesses you are
already
I know I know because they're very
dishonest and they're very satanic
because they don't read the fathers in
context uh the particular section if you
read it what he's saying is why should
it be thought
strange why should it be thought strange
that we believe that Jesus is God In the
Flesh and the Son of God when even you
pagans have beliefs that are similar
Justin martyr's Point wasn't wasn't that
that the Christian faith Finds Its
origin in the Pagan myths or that what
Christians believe is identical to the
pagans he's saying if you condemn us for
believing that Jesus is God In the Flesh
born of a virgin Son of God then what
are you going to say about your Pagan
this you see the point right so he's
trying to make some parallel and
contrast yeah it's like if I were to
talk to a Muslim today and he says to me
well you're idolatrous because you
kissed the cross I go if we're Idol
we kissed the cross then what do you say
about you pagans licking the black
stone that's the analogy of Justin
Martyr see that's what Justin Martyr is
doing he's saying how dare you act
inconsistently how dare you act
hypocritically condemning us for
believing that Jesus is the son of God
Jesus is the son of God born of a virgin
God In the Flesh when you have
beliefs similar beliefs
such as Zeus impregnating women and
having children from them if what we
believe is strange how much more strange
is your belief and if you condemn us why
don't you condemn yourselves it's trying
to say you are acting inconsistently
hypocritically you're acting like
hypocrites